welcome back here to good day las vegas
and as you can see we are joined by
metro sheriff joe lombardo for our
morning cup of joe's segment sheriff
good to see you once again
good to see you john so we have talked
before about budget cuts metro police
had to make when the pandemic started
a lot of budget cuts that had to take
place when our economy recovers
and the funding the tax revenue comes
back to nevada to clark county
what cuts in metro will stay and what of
those cuts will you try and bring back
yeah there was some pretty significant
slicing and dyson
associated with programs and personnel
my primary goal as the sheriff is to
hire police officers so
unfortunately some of the civilian ranks
took a heavy hit we had to
permanently separate some individuals
lay them off not lay them off we had to
just terminate the position
because we we don't anticipate the
ability to hire re-hire those positions
in the short or the long term all of my
part-time positions that were in a
couple hundred positions we had to let
go
so what we're going to do now is some of
those civilian positions that were
vacated we're going to convert them into
police officers positions
and rehire what is metro's uh
guidelines for officers getting the
vaccine and what percentage of the
department is vaccinated now
well let's address the guidelines
question the guidelines is it's
available go get it
i mean that's my direction to them but
it
it's also um under the constraints of
a collective bargaining agreement around
33 percent of my
employee base have received both doses
another five percent is waiting for the
second dose
and the rest have made the arbitrary
decision not to do it
maybe it's just me but it seems like if
you're saying that 33
or so have gotten both doses about 5 are
waiting for that second dose that's
about 60 percent of the department that
has not
or is not getting the vaccine that seems
like a lot to me
yeah it is a lot and your math is
correct and it's unfortunate in that
aspect
but if you look across the industries in
the industry
outside of the medical community those
percentages probably hold
the same across all those industries
let's finally talk about
big events here in the valley obviously
we haven't had really
any of them essentially during the
pandemic but when those
come back i imagine that will be
certainly good news for
officers how much money have officers
lost working whether it's golden knights
games working
at the thomas and mack center working on
the strip elsewhere around the valley
when you say money lost that's extra
money that's not off their paycheck
because all our overtime programs and
special events
within the las vegas valley are are
private
industry paid in other words the
taxpayers are not funding those
programs but in our situation my budget
in the special event world is right
around 25 million a year
hopefully uh the coveted will diminish
and the economy will come back sir
sheriff lombardo thank you very much for
joining us this morning we have as
always appreciate it
if you at home have a question for the
sheriff you can submit it on eight
newsnow dot com
find out if your question is answered
every wednesday